[SPEAKER_00]: 3 a.m. on the 5th of Whale Sun.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul, you're actually getting a little tired because you have been up all day.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the day before, that was the home island, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, you move into the alleyway with Leslie and Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Leslie.
[SPEAKER_00]: In the hallway.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hold on, please.
[SPEAKER_02]: Please tell me that your master had a firebox.
[SPEAKER_02]: Something safe in case there was ever an accident.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do believe I saw that.
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you mean that you saw that?
[SPEAKER_03]: Now you're telling me?
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you mean you saw a firebox?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Dude, okay, I literally, what do you want from me?
[SPEAKER_03]: The place was burnt down.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know what I was looking for, and I spent a total of like two minutes in that house.
[SPEAKER_03]: You made the firebox.
[SPEAKER_03]: Come with me.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what we're after, and he's got any notes that are on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He had a secret compartment under his bed that was stone that he knew how to open.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I say this to them?
[SPEAKER_02]: If you want to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure, but if you don't want to, you don't have to.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why would I not?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because you might want everything inside the box.
[SPEAKER_02]: The option.
[SPEAKER_02]: So please tell me that you know that like what he keeps either like a magic firebox or something to like...
[SPEAKER_01]: I tell you, do I get to look first and you guys get the rest of the stuff?
[SPEAKER_01]: Look first?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean like we need certain things.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's my house.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why would you ask me that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so how about this?
[SPEAKER_02]: How about this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Any notes, any notes that are on the sort of black plague that's happening in the interior, or any notes on the substance that we need to fight the sahuagin, the white powder, or the yellow powder, we need those.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, come with me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will set you up in my tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not only do you need money, you want a new laboratory?
[SPEAKER_00]: Laboratory?
[SPEAKER_00]: To do experiments?
[SPEAKER_00]: And you want to have access to stuff that you can build a factory?
[SPEAKER_00]: How would that be under my bed, though?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's not under your bed.
[SPEAKER_00]: His bed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, that's his knowledge box.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what you're going to be doing is trading that box for stuff from these guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: They obviously need something.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have a protrusive thought in my head.
[SPEAKER_00]: Boy, it was really hard to brainwashed this kid.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was one of the most difficult three seconds of my life.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was thinking hypotheticals there, people.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hypotheticals.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go in the house first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, what?
[SPEAKER_01]: Give me ten minutes.
[SPEAKER_03]: No!
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not going by yourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you can be outside in the front porch.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Acknowledge the burnt flowers.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you say the burnt flowers?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, Leslie.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're outside of a dungeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just saw what I did.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: My inheritance.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you can't.
[SPEAKER_02]: Has he been like this the whole time you've been with him?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, we were swimming in sewage.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if he drank some or what, but I didn't know him before.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a different personality to new people.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, we're not going in 10 minutes early.
[SPEAKER_02]: We all go in, you point it out, we open it, you trust that we need the primary things that we just said, and you can have whatever gold or silver there is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Any diaries or notes?
[SPEAKER_02]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's personal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or recipes?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could I read it first and then give it to you guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I can let you skim over it for five seconds.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_02]: You were talking, you've talked a lot about a lot of different things.
[SPEAKER_02]: If what you want is your own factory, if what you want...
[SPEAKER_01]: Laboratory too.
[SPEAKER_02]: How about as the alchemist's heir or assistant?
[SPEAKER_02]: That you have some financial rights to the production of the yellow chemical.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, this will help you guys, too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: My inventions are going to change the world, and you will get the prototype products after me, of course, and I'm hoping to benefit you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what is in the box benefits me to benefit you guys, to benefit
[SPEAKER_01]: For them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: That benefits me again.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you don't get to go in ten minutes early.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're there together when we open it up.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can guarantee you that I'm not gonna try to like... Yeah, buddy, I don't want your little couple silver pieces, bro.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need more knowledge.
[SPEAKER_01]: I never have enough knowledge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can always have more.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can always know the world.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you need social skills.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're talking to me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want more knowledge, too, so I know right where you're at.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why would I need another person to be as close to me when I could be even more than me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now we're talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now we're talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that's defending me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I speak your language.
[SPEAKER_03]: So why are you defending yourself?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm thinking to myself, these are two wizards, not jobs.
[SPEAKER_01]: You are the dumb wizard.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am a smart wizard who advanced things.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am Leslie.
[SPEAKER_02]: Leslie, I think you might be a little premature in overvaluing yourself.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just need to say that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, what?
[SPEAKER_03]: What are you gonna do?
[SPEAKER_03]: Levitate?
[SPEAKER_01]: My box.
[SPEAKER_01]: His box equals my box equals my money equals my knowledge that I gain.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need access to his knowledge.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll give you some of his knowledge, but I keep the paper.
[SPEAKER_01]: I keep...
[SPEAKER_01]: I go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whose house is it named in?
[SPEAKER_01]: Check the last name, bucko.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you related?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you like a cousin of his?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can legally change your full name, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, technically you've only got Leslie written on your paper.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you're only Leslie.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you could take whatever last name you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, obviously he was your mentor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Leslie the Great, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was your mentor, obviously.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I mean, the obvious inheritor of his stuff is...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, look.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where do you find these people?
[SPEAKER_03]: The alchemists found them.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, you found the alchemist and the alchemist is his.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the alchemist was kind of weird too, okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, so they have inheritance.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you promise that you will make the product in mass, I can guarantee you a constant flow of coin from the royal family.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you mean by mass?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean a lot of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: What inventions do you wish?
[SPEAKER_02]: They need the chemicals.
[SPEAKER_02]: A lot of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, I don't know if we can get you all of the parts of the chemical, but if what you're saying is that you want to retain the proprietorship over this material, like ownership over the recipe, I don't give a shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've been tasked with finding the recipe to make it repeatable.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can at least give five minutes to myself to honor the house.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was my Bible in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You are not a romance.
[SPEAKER_02]: What an anarchist cookbook?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: The gods of the cooks.
[SPEAKER_01]: The gods of the... No.
[SPEAKER_02]: No five minutes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Screw you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I rest in the house.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, we're still in the dungeon.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're in the dungeon!
[SPEAKER_03]: We're, we, this entire conversation with him, do you make a script?
[SPEAKER_02]: Leslie, I think I need you to take a look about where you're at.
[SPEAKER_03]: He slams into a wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need you to ground yourself and look around at where you're at.
[SPEAKER_01]: The stocks are continuously growing in my mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: It could grow even more.
[SPEAKER_01]: So much that it's going backwards on a scale.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you done?
Yes, please.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, Leslie, you're not getting private access.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not asking for private access.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if you're not careful, I'm going to put you in that chair and I'm going to pull every one of your teeth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that illegal?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, nothing down here in the dungeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: The first people I should hire is a lawyer.
[SPEAKER_01]: That is what I get from you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want me to give you guys my stuff so I can make the perfect products, be the inventor, Leslie the Great, and you want me to get a lawyer first.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, look, what I can do is I can promise you that you need to get a commitment from him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get a commitment from him that he is tied to the royal family, will guarantee that you have proprietorship over the manufacturer.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it will be manufactured, listen to me, with or without you, meaning
[SPEAKER_02]: It will either be you doing the making and reaping the profits, or you'll be six feet in the ground or floating in some sewer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, no, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm the CEO, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't know, you don't understand the economy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I borrow, I borrow... Paul, do you have like 20k of food?
[SPEAKER_01]: This will financially change the world, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: I can start out myself and I hire and be a CEO, the owner of the earth, and I make stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: I make cool stuff that people prop on their walls.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're not listening to me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need you to grasp this, and I need you to grasp it quickly, okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I do that many?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's between you and me.
[SPEAKER_01]: How much is your crown?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is my crown?
[SPEAKER_01]: Your royal chair.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you need it?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not giving you my royal chair.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not in the castle.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know what, I'll give you my royal chair.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll let you have the entire lower floors of my castle.
[SPEAKER_00]: So by the way, I want to let you know that Monmurg is the richest city in the Flaness.
[SPEAKER_00]: And his uncle is the richest man in the entire Flaness.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me business partner to business partner.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just want to talk to your uncle.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I don't know if that's gonna happen, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll give you 10% of net income.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, if you can prove, if you can, listen, if we can prove that the recipe works...
[SPEAKER_03]: I was gonna say, get me the stuff that I want first, then I'll hook you up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then we'll hook you up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, then you could probably, you probably will end up talking to him at some point.
[SPEAKER_03]: What about money to buy the stuff?
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, yeah, but we gotta be able to get the components.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just need you to nod your head and to say yes, you're willing to play both.
[SPEAKER_02]: And no, we are not gonna give you five minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't get one minute alone with it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't care if you carry whatever else is in the chest, and that's a lot's coming from me, because if there's some really cool shit in that chest, I'm gonna be kinda... Fine, let's just go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, are you fine with that?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're lucky I haven't invented a pistol yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't even know what a pistol is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, what is that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: A wand with a trigger?
[SPEAKER_02]: A crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: A crossbow you can check.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a kind of crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: A kind, but faster and deadlier.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so we let the guards know to go ahead and throw the Toothless back into his cell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a new name.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so you walk back into the room and you guys have decided on a course of action.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because we're gonna go back.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to go back and check.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need something to drink.
[SPEAKER_03]: You guys want something to drink?
[SPEAKER_01]: A third Gatorade please.
[SPEAKER_03]: You already have two.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I haven't.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, he doesn't need a third.